ça bouge nous sommes à caen pour deux
pièces de théâtre
tout à l'heure nous irons théâtre de
caen pour retrouver pio marmaï dans un
col test mais ici nous sommes au panta
théâtre de caen rue de bretagne pour une
pièce qui s'appelle espia a una mujer
que c'est ma tard que tout vous
expliquer c'est d'après tchekhov l'oncle
vania
comme je perd la mémoire
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu une lettre d'une
maison d'édition on lui demande en
urgence un article pour je ne sais pas
où et je n'ai pas prévu et vous ne
l'avez pas prévu avant demain en
difficulté comme ça vous le terreau est
un peu où elle aura et dormir je veux
continuer à parler je n'ai pratiquement
pas ouvert la bouche depuis que vous
avez commencé un ca des quarante ans
vous ne fait que par les mamans parler
et lire des articles vous croyez pas
qu'il serait temps d'en finir par deux
mois va mieux depuis un an
ça a tellement changé que je ne te
reconnais plus on a toujours l'ombre
portée de tchekhov on a les personnages
on à l'histoire mais allez disons
beaucoup plus ramassé beaucoup plus
énergique
voilà le rapport à la violence aussi
peut-être plus grand c'est c'est aussi
avec une énergie de vie peut être plus
grande encore que chez tchekhov
j'ai 47 ans et comme vous jusqu'à l'an
dernier j'ai passé mon temps à lire des
articles ont clos vania c'est quelqu'un
qui au mieux de sa vie dans une sorte de
crise existentielle aussi les danseuses
de la quarantaine et je sais y'a pas de
ça dont il ya peut-être un côté comme ça
aussi c'est tout d'un coup il se rend
compte qu'il n'a pas fait exactement ce
qu'ils voulaient mais il lui reste un
peu de temps mais pas tant que ça voilà
et puis c'est aussi voilà un monde qui
est en train de changer aussi un petit
feu
c'est aussi des histoires amoureuses
aussi parce que il ya aussi voilà des
triangles amoureux dans ce dans cette
pièce dont ce sont en tout cas voilà
donc il ya aussi ces désirs nouveau qui
bouscule un peu la vie de van hien qui
le perturbe un peu et c'est un peu voilà
des personnages qui sont way au
carrefour de quelque chose et essaie de
retrouver comme ça cette énergie cet
appétit de vivre
cette pièce compressés par un auteur
argentin est à voir au panta théâtre de
caen jusqu'au 16 mars plusieurs
représentations n'hésitez pas or
maintenant retrouver sabine avec pio
marmaï quelle chance chaque nous sommes
sur la scène du théâtre de caen où tout
à leur sera donnée roberto zoko de
koltès avec pio marmaï dans le rôle
principal
roberto succo c'est un jeune homme qui
tue père et mère et qui part en cavale
entre l'italie et la france c'est
quelqu'un qui est comme une sorte de
caméléon comme ça qu'ils s'adaptent aux
gens qu'ils rencontrent et qui
effectivement on va en tout cas c'est ce
que nous pour moi je joue ce n'est qu'un
assez instable désordre d'instabilité
omniprésente mais masse où j'essaie
d'amener là dedans c'est une sorte
d'animalité comme ça que que roberto
succo n'est pas forcément physiquement
c'est dur fario lent qui évinça 20 fois
de suite tous les jours je le ferai plus
alors là je dis je le vois plus je ferai
plus 20 fois de suite d'un spectacle
comme ça c'est un efi personne c'est un
défi ouais j'aime bien j'ai beaucoup
maigri je suis j'étais mal dans le
projet je rêvais que j'ai je tué ma mère
en plusieurs fois mais bon ça ouais ça
ça va ça ça c'est bon c'est fait au
modem on s'assagit quand même je passais
ouais je pense que j'arriverai à voir un
peu distant et au bout d'un moment ça
influence assez influent quand même un
fusil free wheels influent un type comme
dans la vie là après il va falloir
attendre encore dix ans pour cours voire
hautain non dans deux ans je pense que
j'y reviens et je travaillais plus tous
les deux ans sur le spectacle s'est
vidée avoir des projets qui a trouvé oui
sauf si j'ai eu un comportement ringard
du jour au lendemain donc la bombe à
vérin mais dans l'absolu il est possible
qu'en 2018 si un truc web et bas en
attendant trois soirs de suite au
théâtre de caen roberto zuko mise en
scène par richard brunel avec notamment
pio marmaï
merci le cerveau
là ça vous je sommes dans les rues de
caen avec merlin saltimbanques danseurs
de feu alors vous êtes vous êtes vous
produire en spectacle où ça un peu
partout dans le département
on a fait les médiévales de bayeux par
exemple où les mascarades de div
les médiévales d'argence vous disiez que
vous n'êtes pas le voyant de c'est ça
c'est ça non voyants
voilà et vous jonglez quand même et je
jongle quand même parce que bon bah
quand on a la volonté de vouloir relever
des défis et repousser les limites
y a pas de barrière on va rappeler pour
là où ça bouge les dates de spectacles
de merlin et le lui sur des jongleurs de
feu c'est quand ce sera pour la
prochaine date le 5 mars à clichy pour
la fête du feu le film chocolat avec
omar sy et james thierrée est sorti en
janvier dans tout l'hexagone mais demain
soir au café des images
d'hérouville-saint-clair roschdy zem le
réalisateur viendra discuter avec le
public
ghosn et c est là où ça bouge là où ça
bouge c'est sûr françois normandie c'est
bien vous regardez on regarde tout le
temps que je peux avoir un petit café ou
à l'essence reparti après